schüttler hat die 10.000 abonnenten
geknackt vielen dank dafür ich bin heute
in mainz und werde mich um hören was die
bürger deutschland dazu zu sagen haben
[Musik]
schön schlau warte jetzt 10.000
abonnenten was sagen sie dazu
keiner von euch kennt schön schlau
ok
schön schlau hatte jetzt 10.000
abonnenten was sagen sie dazu
[Musik]
ihr habt ihr bestimmt gehört schön
schlau hat jetzt 10.000 abonnenten
was sagt ihr dazu denn schön schlau gar
nicht das ist ein wissens kanal der
jetzt 10.000 abonnenten hat aber leider
kennt ihn niemand kennen wie schön
schlau sagt ihm das war noch nie gehört
habe interessieren sie sich für
naturwissenschaften
[Musik]
wir haben kinder wildungen sowie youtube
wir haben andere youtuber also sie
werden
47 so viel scheiße aber schön schlau das
ist naturwissenschaften sind das keine
fans von naturwissenschaften zu wenig
werbung bei schön schlau auch keine
werbung kennst du schön schlau
[Musik]
er sieht es auch nicht kommen
doch von hinten überholt bei youtube
wir haben